are you doing sir
steve how are you this is the
conversation of the two palest men
in the world we've finally gotten
together
i will take that challenge and say that
i will win that battle against you
i don't know i would point out i'm in
vancouver and it's very
cool here like it doesn't get super hot
we should be in this kind of cloudy
vancouver weather
problem with cloudy weather and being a
pale person is you can be out in the sun
for a while
you think you're safe and all of a
sudden you're just super red
well that's true i mean hey i can get
sunburned looking at a refrigerator
so yeah okay you win all right let's
going into um some actual things did you
take the role in luca
purely to get treated better at
disneyland and disney world
i mean yeah that is a consideration but
honestly
as you know as everyone knows pixar
movies
somehow pixar always sticks the landing
with every movie
it's like for 26 years i don't know how
they do it
i don't know if they're not uh if
legally they're not allowed to make bad
movies
but you know you really
so often in the entertainment industry
and i love to work and
and it's really hard to do quality work
but
somehow pics are always and it's not
like they're doing the same movie over
and over
but they always seem to do something
ambitious
and it works and so i was mostly excited
to be
in a pixar movie and you know being the
father of five children it's like the
first time my kids have ever been
impressed with what i do sure i was
gonna say to you uh being part of pixar
is a really big deal so
actually how much did you pay to be in
the movie i paid
eight thousand 000
i got it that's actually pretty cheap
instead of i really
love this movie and i love the message
of it what did you take away when you
first heard about the script and story
what did what resonated with you the
most
i play a parent so there's so many
themes and
and ideas in this movie that are
brilliant but
i love the idea of how as a parent you
you know it's kind of like not to get to
khalil gabron but like you're
these kids are on loan and you have to
you know you have to be a little
selfless and let them go
on their journey but i also love the
fact
of uh you know i can totally nerd out on
things but i think that it captures
as adults we have this romantic notion
of summer that were
we attempt to uh to achieve
every summer and that that romantic
notion is
established when we're children and so
luca and alberto that summer that
they're having
is what's going to be the the myth of
summer for them in the future and so i
think they capture that
childhood summer idea brilliantly too
switching gears a little bit when was
the last time a director
told you we need to get this in one take
oh well there's certain scenes that are
warners as they say and by the way as
an actor i like that because
uh there's a challenge and that's why i
love indie films really is because
there's often an efficiency of
one take that will allow you
to make choices and nuances that will
that will stay in the story you know
obviously i'm you know
as uh an actor i wanna be a partner in
helping the director or the writer
director
develop their uh their vision you know i
mean i want to be a good partner
but uh yeah i love one takes you know
it's like i love living in the moment it
sounds corny but
it's great uh getting back into luca for
a second
um i would with all animated movies i've
heard that things can really go through
a dramatic change during production
whether it be a character arc whether it
be the whole movie how did uh luca
change for you
during the recording process if at all
you know it didn't
really change that much now i don't
know what was uh happening in the
background
you know i mean or uh and i think that
there
is there is you know and just being a a
fan of pixar i know that there is
um a process that i'm crudely gonna
describe where they kind of have these
focus groups among very selective peers
within the pixar
community so it's not um
and so i don't know how much that shifts
i know that like there's
the legend of that that froze then which
is a disney movie but like that
that changed completely you know i mean
but like
it's it's very rare in a creative
process
for uh a group or a community
to work together but i think that the
input of a community obviously
led by a director is uh
very unique to animation and an
important thing and because
things can adjust and i mean it's not
kind of like hey we already tore down
that set
they can adjust and by the way a lot
million years ago when i did
uh this thing pale force with conan
o'brien
and you would have been in it because
you're so pale is
that is that the thing about animation
is that it's it's inherently editing so
it's kind of like you're never done
you know what i mean like you keep you
can
continue to tinker along the way
i am a huge fan of david lowry and i
know you're
or i think you're still working on i
don't know uh
peter pan and wendy uh what can you tell
people about the project
and what excited you about being in it
yeah you know you know obviously i can't
say
that much but i can say that
um you know i i too am a fan
of david lowry and working with him
it's he is like so up to the
task of this ambition surrounding it
like i have no doubt that this will be
uh not only a great movie but it'll be
the best
peter pan movie you know because like
when
it's something that's been done or
there's been
prequels and and you know like uh you
know
like uh they've done different versions
what's so great about david is that he
has
this balance of of
of grounding things even though it's
dealing in a fantasy
and that he there's a very thoughtful
there's nothing lazy about david lowry
like everything
is and it's weird to work with him
because i'm so exhausted
in the scenes and then he runs off and
he's working with this splinter you know
i'm like i just get tired thinking about
how david laurie's day goes
yeah that's the thing i kind of wanted
to get at is that there's been so many
versions of peter pan
yeah what what is it about this version
that is
like you know different or again what is
it about this version that really
excites you i think well first of all i
think
we know that the animated one
is problematic right i mean everyone
knows that
but i think that
this what excites me about this version
is first of all it's
it's so ambitious to try to do this
you know i mean to because you know it's
not just
you know a time period or a fantasy or
this uh this classic
story that we're dealing with because
also it's it's not
just movie it's the play it's you know
it's the story
it's uh you know it it's kind of like uh
it's almost like
a classic greek story that's part of our
character
but what david has done and what i've
witnessed
is that he's grounded it
but also um made it
uh live a little bit so he's not just
doing a rehash
uh he's not taking you know and not that
not that there's any criticism it's not
like he's taken
like with lion king they just did a
live-action version
jeremy this one is because
of the problems of uh
you know the the insensitivity of
how from our present eyes there's been
a reimagination but it's not done
through
kind of a a
lens of uh
trying to make things right it's just a
reimagining of the story i know i'm
being vague
but it's i get it i get it and it's
moving by the way it's
the story is ever evolving similar to an
indie where
you're constantly in discussion and
what's very exciting is
playing the character of smee there is
it's evolving you know i mean it's not
like david's like
no smith's just an idiot you know what i
mean
i i could ask you a million other things
but i'm totally out of time
i'm just going to say congratulations
being part of this
always a pleasure to talk to you thanks